[Musique]
et on retrouve sur le plateau vincent
hagenbach qu'on sait départementale dans
le canton de kingersheim comment
s'appelle votre binôme c'est josiane
mehlen des terres on aura le temps d'y
revenir mais je crois que ça se passe
plutôt bien avec elle c'est vrai alors
on va partir justement aux portes de
mulhouse c'est un territoire en pleine
mutation entre ville et campagne serment
l'urbanité la ruralité au programme d
aménagement routier tout cela le but
c'est quoi c'est simplement de créer de
l'emploi un collage qui va faire peau
neuve et un petit cours de sport volley
ball c'est parti
vol d'oiseau dessus du couvent de
l'oelenberg nous sommes dans le canton
de kingersheim face à l'unique monastère
cistercien d'alsace ce haut lieu de la
spiritualité garde vivante la mémoire
d'un territoire qui fut bien longtemps
une terre paysanne mais au début du 20e
siècle c'est à plus de 600 mètres sous
les chaudes que se déplacent l'activité
pendant près de quatre-vingt dix ans
l'exploitation des mines de potasse
arrête mais la vie du canton avant de
s'éteindre définitivement au début du
21e siècle
aujourd'hui le canton tire sa richesse
de la proximité de la ville de mulhouse
les activités commerciales remplacer des
emplois industriels en juillet dernier
ouvrait un manche willer un magasin ikea
pour enseigne suédoise qui espère
attirer plus d'un million de clients
chaque année la question de
l'accessibilité était au coeur du choix
de ce site
tout le monde sait que le département a
en charge l'entretien des routes sauf
que est effectivement
il faut aussi voir l'aspect économique
de la chose et si il n'y avait pas eu ce
rond point il n'y aurait pas eu
l'installation d'ikea sur le parc des
collines ikea c'est en tout 150 emplois
équivalents temps plein qui ont été
créés et pour l'économie locale c'est
extrêmement important on va privilégier
les ans les investissements qui
permettent le développement économique
puisqu'on sait quand même que en matière
d'emploi aujourd'hui on a du mal à créer
des postes
la proximité de l'agglomération
mulhousienne attire dans le canton
l'importante population de jeunes actifs
cette expansion démographique impose de
dimensionner les équipements publics en
conséquence le canton compte trois
collèges de ont déjà été rénovés le
conseil départemental s'apprête à lancer
les opérations sur le dernier le collège
de patates nous allons déjà dans un
premier temps pouvoir et devoir agrandir
l'espace extérieur la cour qui est très
petit et il y a aussi un travail au
niveau de la chaufferie affaire il y a
les huisseries qui sont très très très
vétuste il faut aujourd'hui que les
collèges soient des lieux
l'épanouissement et pour cela il faut un
minimum de d'aménagement et je crois
qu'il ya un gros travail qui doit être
fait aussi sur l'aspect énergétique et
l'aspect sécuritaire de nokia
le sport lutterbach équipement communal
cette salle de sport est sorti de terre
avec le soutien financier du conseil
départemental
objectif offrir aux collégiens aller aux
associations du village un équipement
dernier cri un codec à cela
d'intéressant c'est qu'il sert sur le
temps scolaire au collège et sur le
temps extrascolaire aux associations et
donc à tous les jeunes pour une commune
comme luther bac c'est très important
parce que sans salle de sport et samson
aux salles d'activités et bien il n'ya
tout simplement pas de lien social
possible il faut des équipements il faut
permettre le développement du sport il
faut permettre aux jeunes de pouvoir se
rencontrer travailler en équipe évoluer
c'est extrêmement important
est peut-être à lutterbach s'entraînent
déjà dur champions
vous le souhaitez à quai des futurs
champions benjamin toniutti est issu de
notre canton puisqu'il est faste à toi
voilà vincent hagenbach vous êtes notre
invité il ya 57 collèges dans le
département alors on a vu celui de
flashbacks qui va être rénové des
investissements plutôt lourd qui vont
être décidées comment est ce qu'on
décide quels fonds départementaux on met
sur tel ou tel collège comment ça se
passe d'abord il faut rappeler qu'avec
la loi réduisant les activités des
différents cantons faut pas oublier
qu'on n'a pas forcément d'autres
solutions que de revenir sur notre coeur
de métier et sur nos compétences réelles
dont les collèges font véritablement
partie sur et ensuite il ya
véritablement un travail qui est fait
pour voir quels sont ceux qui sont le
plus dans le besoin et c'est vrai que
c'est sur lui aux relations l'urgence
absolument et je pense qu'on n'a pas
d'autre possibilité que de travailler en
tiroir en réalisant un certain nombre de
travaux qui permettent d'en de libérer
d'autres d'autres possibilités pour
avancer petit à petit pour rénover les
collèges dont ceux de celui de fast and
as vraiment grandement besoin
actuellement on voit que la ville gagne
du terrain sur votre territoire c'est
d'ailleurs une de ses spécificités votre
canton et autant rural qu'urbain c'est
ça on y tient beaucoup et on a cette
chance puisque nous sommes élus
départementaux d'un des plus petits
cantons du département du haut rhin il
comporte huit communes dont trois sont
véritablement rural à savoir galfingue
heimsbrunn reiningue et le reste est
beaucoup plus péri urbain notamment donc
lutterbach faste à richwiller
morschwiller le bas et kingersheim c'est
intéressant quand on voit ces images là
avec ce magasin suédois et qu'on entend
votre binôme qui dit voilà sans le
rond-point n'aurais pas pu le faire
c'est vrai qu'il faut toujours un
maillage comme ça avec toutes les
compétences départementales et
régionales tout à fait on a vu les
différentes compétences du cb un routier
éducation aménagement du territoire il
nous manque encore la solidarité on va
l'évoqué ça se passe chez vous à
richwiller il vous êtes le maire
d'ailleurs de richwiller tout est
parlons de 7
ehpad à ça a été une aventure de
nombreuses années puisque le projet on a
commencé à évoquer dans les années 2000
2,8 et en fait il a été inauguré au
courant de l'année 2014 donc c'est un
peu un projet remarquable puisque c'est
n'est pas entièrement réalisé deux
pleins plis pied avec donc on va bien
sûr la mutualité française qui est le
principal promoteur mais il ya eu un
travail de collaboration et de
partenariat très intense avec la commune
de riches et là bien évidemment qui a
mis à disposition un hectare cadre de
terrain et bien sûr le département du
haut rhin qui joue son qui a joué son
rôle aussi bien dans l'investissement
1,1 million d'euros sur les douze ça
fait plus de 15 % et l'aco et à côté de
ça il ya bien sûr une participation de
tout à fait annuel du département dans
le fonctionnement aujourd'hui puisque ce
sont près de 400000 euros qui sont que
le département met à disposition dans
les frais de fonctionnement aussi bien
dans le cadre de l'apa que de l'aide aux
personnes les plus dans le besoin et
qu'ils ont besoin par contre d'être dans
cette danse était pâle voilà il a
l'argent aussi des départements demande
où il passe il passe vraiment dans du
concret s'affaire maintenant un an que
l'assemblée départementale a été élu et
pas mal de nouveaux visages quel bilan
peut faire moi je m'épanouis pleinement
avec et notamment avec mon binôme et je
pense que c'est également le cas de la
majorité de nos collègues élus pour une
simple raison c'est qu'il ya une vraie
volonté de travail c'est une équipe qui
marche bien c'est une équipe qui
fonctionne très bien je crois on est
parfaitement conscient aujourd'hui nos
moyens sont plutôt limitées se sont
restreints mais je pense que c'est dans
ce cadre là même si c'est très très
difficile dans le cas de cette
difficulté qu'on voit là on arrivera
vraiment être de bons gestionnaires ou
pas on en parle régulièrement entre vous
des budgets qui sont très serrés pour le
haut rhin ont surtout les départements
voilà c'est dit oui tout à fait c'est
quelque chose c'est une discussion que
nous avons régulièrement
aujourd'hui il ya une chose qui est
essentiel c'est de cette parité qui
était probablement une crainte pour
certains on l'avait déjà vécu au niveau
des municipales précédemment mais je
crois que la parité a été un c'est un
vrai bonheur parce que je crois que ces
dames dans ces assemblées ont cette
capacité de travail déjà pour commencer
mais également du dynamisme et
d'apporter d'autres une autre vision des
choses est franchement
quand on voit l'engouement qu'il ya au
niveau des commissions où nous sommes
vraiment nombreuses qui change un petit
peu peut-être de ce qui se faisait
jusqu'à maintenant on est vraiment
nombreux et le travail est fait vrai
véritablement collaboration en équipe et
ben justement comment ça se passe avec
votre vidéo autrement dit comment vous
travaillez tous les deux qui fait quoi
alors on travaille totalement ensemble
on a cette chance de ne couvrir que huit
communes ce qui nous permet de re est de
travailler quasiment ensemble sur
l'ensemble des dossiers on est dans la
plupart des situations nous sommes
ensemble sur le terrain lorsqu'on a une
invitation les deux participants aux
invitations et répondre aux invitations
qu'on nous propose on travaillait
ensemble véritablement main à la main
les dossiers sont portées ensemble je
crois qu'il ya personne aucun d'entre
nous il ya tout simplement les liens
d'amitié entre josiane et moi qui était
antérieure à notre élection au
département vous êtes bien tombé là
dessus on est vraiment quoi dire
franchement on pouvait pas mieux tomber
on travaille ensemble au niveau de
communes depuis près de huit ans dans
des domaines très compliqué qui sont
notamment le l'occupation des jeunes
enfants durant les périodes de vacances
et donc on s'était presque c'est tout à
fait naturel notre façon de travailler
je crois qu on se téléphone quasiment
tous les jours au moins une fois donc
dès 8h le matin donc franchement in iz
c'est avant tout un lien d'amitié qui
nous permet de réaliser des choses très
intéressantes voilà en gros 10 secondes
ce n'est pas le même métier maire de
votre commune et conseil départemental
si ça se ressemble beaucoup parce que
les skis change véritablement c'est de
ce sont les périmètres c'est les
compétences d'une manière ou d'une autre
on les retrouve quand on parle de budget
aujourd'hui au niveau communal qui va
être votée le 22 mai il va être voté au
niveau de l'intercommunalité et du
département dans les semaines qui
suivent la même chose ce n'est pas les
mêmes séries sera là ce ne sont pas les
mêmes territoires